Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. If atomic bombs are to be added as new weapons to the arsenals of a warring world, or to the arsenals of nations preparing for war, then the time will come when mankind will curse the names of Los Alamos and Hiroshima. The peoples of this world must unite or they will perish. This war, that has ravaged so much of the earth has written these words. The atomic bomb has spelled them out for all men to understand.
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听权限，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。如果原子弹将作为新武器加入交战世界或备战国家的军火库，那么人类终将诅咒洛斯阿拉莫斯和广岛这两个名字。世界各国人民必须团结起来，否则将共同毁灭。这场蹂躏了地球大部分地区的战争已经写下了这些话。原子弹将其清晰地拼写出来，让所有人都能理解。
Other men have spoken them in other times of other wars of other weapons. They have not prevailed. There are some, misled by a false sense of history, who hold that they will not prevail today. It is not for us to believe that. By our works, we are committed, committed to a world united before this common peril in law and in humanity. So that, Dominic, was J. Robert Oppenheimer talking in the wake of the dropping of the atom bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki as he was leaving Los Al pretty much the tone of a Frankenstein, isn't it? Someone who has created something that he kind of regrets, perhaps. I mean, there's definitely a tone of regret there. Absolutely. So hello, everybody. Last time we were talking about the early life of J. Robert Oppenheimer, the godfather of the atomic bombs, Tom called him, and then later a Cold War martyr. We got up to the point
其他人曾在其他时期的其他战争和面对其他武器时说过这些话。但他们并没有成功。有些人被对历史的错误理解所误导，认为他们今天也不会成功。我们不能这样认为。通过我们的行动，我们矢志不渝，致力于在这个共同的危险面前，在法律和人道主义的基础上建立一个团结的世界。多米尼克，这就是J·罗伯特·奥本海默在广岛和长崎投下原子弹后，即将离开洛斯时所说的话……这几乎就是弗兰肯斯坦的语气，对吧？一个创造了某种他或许有点后悔的事物的人。我的意思是，里面绝对有一种后悔的语气。完全同意。大家好。上一次我们聊到了J·罗伯特·奥本海默的早年生活，汤姆称他为原子弹之父，后来又成了冷战烈士。我们讲到了……
where they did the Trinity test. So that's in July 1945. And that quote you read out there, Tom, is it's just a few months later, but the mood has very much changed. And what has changed from Oppenheimer's mood of almost sort of ecstatic relief when the nuclear test worked to October, when he finally leaves Los Alamos is the fact that the bomb has been demonstrated twice in Japan and in Hiroshima and Nagasaki, as you say. Does he have a sense at this point that the bomb that he has worked so long and hard to bring into being might well lead to the destruction of life on earth i think everybody who worked at los alamos from let's say 1943 to 1945 i think everybody who did that knew that there were ethical issues with the
他们进行三位一体测试的时候。那是1945年7月。汤姆，你刚才读的那段引言，就在几个月后，但气氛已经发生了很大变化。从奥本海默在核试验成功时那种近乎狂喜的解脱感，到10月他最终离开洛斯阿拉莫斯时，改变的是事实——正如你所说，原子弹已经在日本、广岛和长崎被两次展示。他此时是否有一种感觉：他花了那么长时间和心血制造出来的原子弹，很可能会导致地球上生命的毁灭？我认为，从1943年到1945年，所有在洛斯阿拉莫斯工作过的人，我认为所有做过这件事的人都知道，原子弹存在伦理问题……
bomb that it would kill an enormous number of people i think they are they are completely dedicated to the project as we talked about last. They always really thought of it as a weapon against Nazi Germany. And many of them, because some of them have Jewish heritage, because many of them are politically very idealistic and they're on the left, they have a passion. They see this as an absolute crusade. But they also see it, as Oppenheimer said after the test, as a weapon that will save lives, a weapon that will end wars, a super weapon that will render all other weapons obsolete. But do you think that he is starting to think that's naive when he gives that speech? So there are reports, somebody says that a few days after the test, they see him and he's just muttering to himself, those poor little people, those poor little people. And he's talking about the people on whom the bomb will be dropped. Because, of course, by this point, the focus has moved to Japan. So Japan is still in the war, but Germany isn't.
它会杀死大量的人。我认为他们完全致力于这个项目，正如我们上次讨论的那样。他们其实一直把它当作对抗纳粹德国的武器。他们中的许多人，因为有些人有犹太血统，因为他们许多人在政治上非常理想主义并且属于左翼，所以他们有着极大的热情。他们将此视为一场绝对的十字军东征。但正如奥本海默在测试后所说，他们也将此视为一把拯救生命的武器，一把将结束战争的超级武器，一把将使所有其他武器过时的超级武器。但你认为他在发表那次演讲时，开始觉得这很天真了吗？所以有报道称，有人说在测试几天后，看到他在喃喃自语：“那些可怜的人，那些可怜的人。”他指的是将被投掷原子弹的人。因为当然，到这个时候，焦点已经转移到了日本。所以日本还在参战，但德国已经不在了。
And I know last time you were keen to talk about the decision to drop the bomb, weren't you? Because it is a massive historiographical issue. And it's so complicated that we don't want to, I mean. Well, let's do it. We'll do an episode on the dropping of the bombs on Hiroshima. So we'll leave it for that. But I think let's just to focus on Oppenheimer himself and his relationship both to Truman, so the civilian chain of command, and to the military.
我知道上次你很想谈谈投放原子弹的决定，对吧？因为这是一个巨大的史学问题。而且它太复杂了，我们不想……我的意思是。好吧，我们来谈谈吧。我们会专门做一集关于在广岛投放原子弹的节目。所以我们留到那一集再讲。但我想，我们还是专注于奥本海默本人，以及他与杜鲁门（即文官指挥链）和军方的关系。
Does he have any input at all into whether it should be dropped or not? No. That decision is made in Washington two weeks after Truman became president. So Truman became president on the 12th of April when FDR died. So FDR died. He's at his retreat in Warm Springs, Georgia. He has a massive stroke. He's been very ill for a long time. Truman, who is a former haberdasher from Kansas City, Missouri, takes over a little man, very undervalued. Nobody really, people are shocked that Truman is the president. He's not a great figure to conjure with. So when I went to the Capitol and was shown around around it wonderful tour um and there was a splendid statue of truman and the the key thing on that statue was the fact he was wearing glasses which you don't
他对是否应该投放原子弹有任何发言权吗？没有。这个决定是在杜鲁门成为总统两周后在华盛顿做出的。所以杜鲁门是在4月12日罗斯福总统逝世时成为总统的。富兰克林·罗斯福（FDR）去世了。当时他在佐治亚州温泉市的休养所里。他突发严重中风。他已经病得很久了。杜鲁门，这位来自密苏里州堪萨斯城的原男装店老板，接任了总统职务。他是个小个子，非常被低估。没有人真正……人们对杜鲁门当总统感到震惊。他不是一个呼风唤雨的伟大人物。所以当我去国会山参观时，导游带我进行了精彩的参观……那里有一尊杜鲁门的精美雕像，雕像最关键的一点是他戴着眼镜，这在雕像中并不常见。
see very often in statues he's a little man with glasses he's uh he he looks i mean this is very important to truman he's not intellectual um he does have a military record but he's not a titanic figure he's not a natural leader he. He's not a natural leader. He, in his own mind, is the American everyman, the soul of kind of main street, small town America. Slightly Stanley Baldwin. Tiny bits. Middle England, middle America.
常见。他是个戴着眼镜的小个子男人，他……他看起来——我的这对杜鲁门非常重要——他不是一个知识分子……他的确有从军经历，但他不是一个泰斗级人物，他不是一个天生的领袖。他不是一个天生的领袖。在他自己心里，他是美国的老百姓，是那种美利坚主街、小镇风情的灵魂。有点像斯坦利·鲍德温。有一点点。英格兰腹地，美国腹地。
It's a bit like, I mean, obviously the fact that he follows Roosevelt as Attlee does Churchill. There's a sort of sense of bespectacled little men replacing great, colorful patricians. Now, Truman is told about the bomb about two weeks after he becomes president by Henry Stimson. His Secretary of State, James
这有点像……显然，他追随罗斯福，就像艾德礼追随丘吉尔一样。有一种戴着眼镜的小人物取代了伟大、多姿多彩的贵族的感。现在，杜鲁门在成为总统大约两周后，由亨利·史汀生告知了原子弹的事。他的国务卿詹姆斯·伯恩斯非常渴望他使用原子弹。有很多人。我的意思是，你会使用它有不同的原因。你显然会使用它，因为你想在他们对日本本土发动进攻时避免美军伤亡。美国人在冲绳付出了巨大的伤亡代价，日本人战斗到了最后一个人。他们担心类似的发动入侵将带来巨大的伤亡。他们还……在某些历史学家中存在着一派观点，即他们对斯大林、对苏联以及对正在形成的冷战有着清醒的认识。
Burns, is very keen for him to use it. There are lots of people. I mean, there are different reasons why you would use it. You would obviously use it because you want to avoid American casualties when they launched the attack on the japanese home islands the americans had incurred colossal casualties in okinawa the japanese had fought to the last man they're worried that a similar invasion will will incur huge casualties they also um there there is a whole school of thought among some historians that they are very conscious of Stalin and of the Soviet Union, of the emerging Cold War.
所以他们基本上想展示美国的实力。是的，他们想展示美国的实力。他们还想尽快结束太平洋战争，因为斯大林正准备对日本宣战。所以他们想按自己的条件结束战争，并向斯大林发出信号。另一方面，有些历史学家说，好吧，听着……顺便说一句，政府内部也有人持有这种观点，在争论这件事。所以有人说……
So they want to basically demonstrate American power. Yeah, they want to demonstrate American power. They also want to shut down the war in the Pacific as quickly as possible because Stalin is poised to declare war on Japan himself. So they want to shut it down on their terms and send Stalin a signal. On the other side, there are historians who say, well, listen, I mean, there were people, by the way, within the administration having this argument. So there were people who say,
日本无论如何也快要投降了。我的意思是，日本已经日薄西山了。日本的一些消息来源暗示，他们正在朝着某种有条件的投降迈进，只要他们能保留天皇——当然他们最后也确实保留了天皇。因为战争的发展不一定……
Japan is about to surrender anyway. I mean, Japan is on its last legs. There are some hints from sources in Japan that they are moving towards some kind of conditional surrender as long as they can keep the emperor, which of course they end up doing. Because the war has not been developing
对日本有利。没错。事实上，甚至有很多相当鹰派的人，比如那些参与轰炸东京等任务的人，后来也说轰炸广岛是不必要的。
necessarily to Japan's advantage. Correct. And in fact, even there are a lot of quite hawkish people, actually people working on the bombing of Tokyo and things, who say later the bombing of Hiroshima is unnecessary.
现在，这不是我们在播客里花三分钟就能解决的问题。所以我们留到以后关于广岛本身的节目再讲。但还是回到奥本海默身上。奥本海默并不在那些人当中。他没有参与这些对话。但在原子弹爆炸之后，这在实际意义上意味着什么的发现在，这会影响他吗？这会改变他对……
Now, this is not an argument that we can settle in three minutes in this podcast. So let's save that for a later episode on Hiroshima itself. But sticking to Oppenheimer. Oppenheimer is not part of those. He's not part of those conversations. But in the wake of the bombs, does the discovery of what this means in practical terms, does this affect him? Does it change his views on what
他所做的事情的看法吗？是的，或者以复杂且略显惊讶的方式。事情是这样的，1945年8月6日，他们得到了消息，埃诺拉·盖伊号已经在广岛投下了原子弹，原子弹已经爆炸，一切都按计划进行，炸死了许多人，换句话说……那天晚上，人群聚集在洛斯阿拉莫斯的礼堂里——他们为这个新镇建造了设施，所以有一个大礼堂，大家可以聚集在那里开会、搞娱乐活动什么的。他们都聚在一起，奥本海默走了进来，迎接他的是狂热的掌声和欢呼声。目击者说他把双手举过头顶交握，
he's done or yes or what but in complicated ways and slightly surprising ways so the story goes on the 6th of august 1945 they get the news that the enola gay has dropped the bomb on hiroshima it has gone off everything has gone according to plan it's killed lots of people and exactly in other words that evening a crowd gathers in the auditorium at los alamos so they have built facilities for the you know it's a new town so there is a big auditorium where they can all gather and and have um meetings and things or for entertainments or whatever they all gather oppenheimer comes in and he is greeted with rapturous applause and cheers. And the eyewitnesses say he's clasping his hands above his head,
你知道的，就像某种拳击冠军一样。是的，我们成功了。祝贺。太棒了，大家干得好。万岁，万岁。所以有这样的一面。毫无疑问，那天晚上确实有一些人举行了派对，科学家们在庆祝原子弹的投下。
you know, like a kind of boxing champion. Yes, we've done it. Congratulations. Wonderful. Well done, everybody. Hurrah, hurrah. So there's that side to it. And there's no doubt that that night some people did hold parties, scientists, to celebrate the dropping
另一方面，有报道称，当一些人在狂欢时，另一些人却在呕吐，因为他们感到如此内疚，内心充满了矛盾。我想随着时间的推移，特别是日本投降后，他们当中越来越多的人，包括奥本海默在内，开始感到非常非常内疚。奥本海默一直否认自己感到内疚。他说：“我感到一种沉重的责任感，这与内疚不完全是一回事。”一位科学家的妻子说，随着时间的推移，我们对邪恶的现实产生了极其个人化的体验。在他们为这个倾注了如此多心血的项目工作了这么长时间之后，说出这样的话真是非同寻常。联邦调查局（FBI）的档案显示——当然，正如我们上次所说，FBI一直在监视奥本海默，监听他的电话，窃听他的办公室。
of the atom bomb on the other hand there are stories that there are while some people are partying there are other people who are being physically sick because they are so they feel so full of guilt and and they're so conflicted about this and I think as time goes on, especially once Japan has surrendered, more and more of them, Oppenheimer included, start to feel very, very guilty. Oppenheimer always denied that he felt guilty. He said, I feel just a crushing burden of responsibility, which is not quite the same as guilt. And one scientist's wife said, as time went on, we felt an intensely personal experience of the reality of evil. Extraordinary thing to say after they've been working so long on this project that they were so devoted to. The FBI files, because of course, as we said last time, the FBI are surveilling Oppenheimer the whole time, tapping his phones, wiretapping his office. fbi files say that he's a nervous wreck
FBI的档案说他精神崩溃了，郁郁寡欢、离群索居，烟抽得更凶了，一分钟抽一千根烟什么的……确切地说。当然，讽刺的是，他现在成了一个名人，对许多美国人来说他是个英雄，他登上了杂志封面，成了赢得战争的人，赢得战争的人，对吧？所以我们讨论了普罗米修斯这个梗，因为凯·伯德和马丁·J·舍曼写的那本关于他的书（克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影就是根据这本书改编的）叫做《美国普罗米修斯》。在几周后，美国几大期刊之一的《科学月刊》发表了一篇大报道，他们是这样说的：我们现代的普罗米修斯突袭了奥林匹斯山，为人类带回了上帝的雷霆。
that he is morose and withdrawn and smoking even more heavily smoking a thousand cigarettes a minute or whatever exactly of course the irony is that he is now a celebrity he's a hero to a lot of americans he's put on magazine covers the man who won the war the man who won the war right so we talked about uh the prometheus thing because the book on him by kai bird and martin j sherman on which the christopher nolan film is based is called american prometheus scientific monthly a few uh big american periodical a few weeks after this run a big story and this is what they said our modern prometheans have raided mount olympus, and they have brought back for man
但你知道吗，有没有人在使用弗兰肯斯坦的比喻？我想没有。因为当然，在这个时候，他们认为，许多人认为这是我们的，这是美国的炸弹。这让我们变得不可触碰、坚不可摧。但美国一定有种感觉，苏联在某个时候也会造出这枚炸弹，对吧？是的，绝对有。事实上，即使在这个阶段，汤姆，也有人说，这还不够。有些人基本上在预测军备竞赛。
the very thunderbolt of his use. But do you know, I mean, is anyone using the Frankenstein metaphor? I don't think so. Because of course, at this point, they think, a lot of people think this is ours, this is America's bomb. And this has made us untouchable, impregnable. But the US must have a sense that the Soviets are going to be getting this bomb as well, at some point, right? Yeah, absolutely. And in fact, even at this stage, Tom, there are some people who say, well, this is not enough. There are some people who say, who are basically predicting the arms race.
所以奥本海默的一位同事——我们上次非常简短地提到过他，一个名叫爱德华·泰勒的匈牙利裔家伙。泰勒在科学界是一个非常有争议的人物，因为他和奥本海默在本集中将有着非常纠葛的关系。他将在奥本海默的故事中扮演一个近乎浮士德式的角色。真令人惊叹，在这个故事中，竟然有这么多这样的神话原型可以轻易被唤起。即使在此时，泰勒也在呼吁制造一种更好的武器。他当时称之为“超级炸弹”。人们称之为超级炸弹。但我们会称之为氢弹，即氢弹。
So there's one of Oppenheimer's colleagues that we mentioned last time very briefly, a chap called Edward Tellerer who's of hungarian heritage uh teller is a very controversial person in the scientific community um because he and oppenheimer will in this episode have a very tangled relationship he's going to play a a sort of almost faustian kind of part in oppenheimer's story it's amazing how how many of these kind of mythic archetypes yeah readily invocable in this story and teller even at this, is calling for a better weapon. He calls it, at that point, the super. People call it the super. But we would call it the H-bomb, the hydrogen bomb.
所以他就是奇爱博士。在20世纪90年代，人们经常问他——因为他活到了137岁左右——人们会对他说：“你就是奇爱博士，对吧？”他会非常生气，当场终止采访。但他绝对是在说：“我们需要这种炸弹，它有第二阶段，基本上成为一枚聚变弹，其爆炸威力比广岛和长崎要大得多。”即便在此时，奥本海默也说：“这不好。我们不需要走那么远。”泰勒对此感到非常非常生气。即使在此时，非常生气。即使在此时，我们谈论的是1945年的夏天到秋天，奥本海默实际上已经开始在某些方面与他自己的名气和项目保持距离了。因为你是从那句引言开始的，也就是10月16日他离开洛斯阿拉莫斯时的那次演讲。他又回到了那种理想主义、世界政府、国际主义的东西中。所以联合国的成立，联合国的成立也是这个故事背景的一部分，这种对某种普世全球秩序的梦想。
So he's Dr. Strangelove. People used to ask him in the 1990s, because he lived to the age of about 137. And people would say to him, you're Dr. Strangelove, aren't you? And he would get very cross and terminate the interview then and there. But he absolutely is saying, we need this bomb that has a second stage where we basically become a fusion bomb, and it's an infinitely bigger explosion than Hiroshima and Nagasaki. And even at this point, Oppenheimer says, that's bad.
绝对是的。那些热爱联合国的人——我的意思是，甚至当我还是个男孩的时候，我都记得有些人会喋喋不休地谈论联合国，非常充满激情，对它非常理想主义，会去参加联合国俱乐部之类的地方。
We don't need to go that far. And Teller is very, very cross about this. And even at this point, very cross about this. And even at this point, we're talking about the summer into the autumn of 1945, Oppenheimer is already actually, in some ways, beginning to distance himself from his own fame and his own project. Because you began with that quote, that speech the 16th of October when he left Los Alamos. He's back into his kind of idealism, world government, internationalism stuff. So the UN is being, the founding of the
他们就是奥本海默在20世纪30年代在伯克利与之交往的那类激进分子、理想主义者的传人。就在他离开洛斯阿拉莫斯那次演讲的九天后，他去见了哈里·杜鲁门，这是他第一次见到杜鲁门。他走进白宫，对杜鲁门说：“总统先生，我觉得我的手上沾满了鲜血。”你知道杜鲁门说什么吗？“这个养的。”
UN is also part of the backdrop of this story, this dream of a kind of universal global order. Absolutely. And those people who love the UN, I mean, even when I was a boy, I can remember there'd be some people who would like bang on about the UN, very passionate, very idealistic about it, going to go to UN clubs and stuff.
是的。差不多是这个意思。他勃然大怒，对吧？据说他对他说：“没关系，洗洗就干净了。”好吧，他是个男装店老板。然后奥本海默一离开，杜鲁门就转身对他的助手们说：“我再也不想在这个办公室里看到这个养的了。”
And they are the heirs of those kind of radical people, idealistic people, that Oppenheimer had been associating with at Berkeley in the 1930s. So nine days after that speech, when he left Los Alamos, he went to meet Harry Truman for the first time. And he goes into the White House and he says to Truman, Mr. President, I feel I have blood on my hands. And do you know what Truman said? Son of a bitch.
妈的，他手上的血还没我的一半多呢！然后他到处说：“我接待了一个讨厌的爱哭鬼科学家。”所以有些人——我的意思是，在我看来，杜鲁门实际上是一位被严重低估的总统。但如果你是一个批评杜鲁门的人，你会说这是一个根本不知道自己在说什么、完全力不从心的人。他试图通过装硬汉、扮演硬汉来过度补偿。因为关于这一点，有报道称，当第一次试验发生时，比方说在洛斯阿拉莫斯，人们报告说奥本海默昂首阔步，就像正午时分的牛仔一样。是的，他为此感到自己被赋予了力量，仿佛高人一等。但现在他成了这个爱哭鬼科学家。
Yeah. Where's that effect? He's furious, isn't he? He said to him, supposedly, he said to him, never mind, it'll come out in the wash. Well, he's a haberdasher. And then as soon as Oppenheimer leaves, Truman turned to his aides and he said, I don't want ever to see that son of a bitch in this office again.
汤姆，我觉得这是一个非常棘手的问题，因为实际上，即使在《美国普罗米修斯》这本书中——这本书非常支持奥本海默——他们也有这样一个故事。我的意思是，值得称赞的是，他们收录了一个故事，讲述了一个在晚年非常了解奥本海默的人的故事，当时奥本海默在加勒比海的一个岛屿上度过了很多时间，也就是美属维尔京群岛的圣约翰岛。这些人说，每年的8月6日，奥本海默和他的妻子都会这样做，会非常自鸣得意地昂首阔步。这是他们的重大周年纪念日。这是他们的日子，广岛轰炸日。你一方面有这种表现，另一方面，你又看到奥本海默到处说：“我手上沾满了鲜血，我感觉太糟糕了，”然后表现得郁郁寡欢、离群索居、忧郁。哪一个是真的？好吧，真相可能两者兼有。
Damn it, he hasn't half as much blood on his hands as I have. Then he goes around saying, I've had a visit from this awful crybaby scientist. So some people, I mean, Truman actually is a greatly underrated president in my view. But if you were a Truman critic, you would say this is somebody who basically doesn't know what he's talking about and is totally out of his depth. Overcompensating by trying to be a tough guy, play the tough guy. Because on that, there are reports, aren't there, when the first test happened, say back at Los Alamos, people report that Oppenheimer kind of struts around like he's a cowboy in high noon. Yes. That he feels kind of empowered by it, kind of raised up. But now he's become this crybaby scientist.
完全有可能两者兼有。也许他是一个复杂、微妙的人，他既对自己的成就感到无比自豪，认为这结束了战争，但显然他也确实感到了巨大的内疚和一种……汤姆，如果你不感到一丝内疚，你就是个怪物，对吧？我的意思是，在某种意义上，对于大国而言，直到今天，拥有核武器既是他们地位的象征，与此同时，拥有核武器显然意味着你可以毁灭世界。是的，当然。
I think it's a really difficult one, Tom, because actually, even in the American Prometheus book, which is very pro-Oppenheimer, they have a story. I mean, to their credit, they've included a story from somebody who knew Oppenheimer much later in life when he spent a lot of time in a Caribbean island, the island of St. John's in the US Virgin Islands. And these people said that on the 6th of August every year, Oppenheimer and his wife would do exactly that, would kind of strut around very smugly. This was their big anniversary. This was their day, the bombing of Hiroshima. You have that on the one hand, and then on the other hand, you have Oppenheimer going around saying, I have blood on my hands, I feel so awful, being kind of morose and withdrawn and melancholy. And which of those are true? Well, the truth could be both. Exactly. Maybe both are true. Maybe he's a complicated, nuanced man, and he feels both
我的意思是，人们对它们有复杂的看法，这很正常。我认为，在某些方面，这并不……你和我不需要解决奥本海默性格中的这种矛盾。
enormous pride at his achievement that he thinks ended the war, but also he clearly does feel great guilt and a sense of, you know, you'd be a monster, Tom, if you didn't feel a bit of guilt, wouldn't you? I mean, there is a sense in which for great powers, even to this day, the possession of nuclear weapons is a totem of their status, while at the same time, obviously, possessing a nuclear weapon means that you can kind of destroy the world. Yeah, of course.
它可以就那么存在着。而且我认为它确实存在。好吧。所以他离开洛斯阿拉莫斯。是的。他接下来要去干什么？好吧，他实际上有效地……奥本海默的性格。它可以就那么存在着。而且我认为它确实存在。好吧。所以他离开洛斯阿拉莫斯。是的。他接下来要去干什么？好吧，他实际上有效地……这很有趣。
I mean, of course people have complicated views about them. I think it's, um, in some ways it doesn't, we don't have to, you and I don't have to resolve that contradiction in Oppenheimer's personality.
他的职业生涯，他作为物理学家的职业生涯基本上已经结束了。他已经江郎才尽了。在某种程度上，他已经离开实验室很久了。他一直在管理那个小镇。物理学似乎对他不再那么重要了。从长远来看，这部分是因为发现的步伐把他抛在了后面吗？如果他花了五年时间管理洛斯阿拉莫斯，他就没有时间跟上那个必然令人难以置信的动荡的发现和创新时期了吗？完全是这样。我的意思是……
It can just be there. And I think it was there. Okay. So he leaves Los Alamos. Yeah. And what is he going off to do? Well, he actually goes off effectively.heimer's personality. It can just be there. And I think it was there. Okay. So he leaves Los Alamos. Yeah. And what is he going off to do? Well, he actually goes off effectively. It's interesting.
当我们第一集谈到20世纪20年代的物理学时，我们说过这是一个年轻人的游戏，而他已经不再年轻了。你知道的，他几岁了？他四十多岁了吧？他一直在进行大量的官僚斗争。
His career, his career as a physicist is pretty much over. So he's out of ideas. In some ways, he's been out of the lab for a long time. He's been running the town. Physics just doesn't seem relevant to him anymore and he in the long run is that partly because the the the pace of discovery has left him behind that if he's if he's spent five years kind of running los alamos he hasn't had time to keep abreast of what must be an incredibly turbulent period of discovery and innovation exactly i mean
我喜欢认为那还算挺年轻的。你觉得那还算年轻？是的，嗯，我完全明白你的意思。但是，你知道，如果有一些才华横溢的22岁物理学家崭露头角……我的意思是，奥本海默对他们来说……奥本海默已经成了老黄历了。他也是一个建制派人物，你知道的，他是企业美国和军工复合体的象征……是的，绝对是的。但我的意思是，有一件事是我们不能低估的，我想我们在上一集里也说过，他一直受到FBI和美国陆军情报人员的监视。这从未停止过。就在他与哈里·杜鲁门进行那次灾难性的会面几周后，J·埃德加·胡佛向杜鲁门发送了他FBI档案的摘要，他说：“我们确凿地认为他曾是共产党成员。”实际上没有证据证明这一点，但他们就是这么说的。他们还说：“我们还认为他与共产党仍有联系。”有一个惊人的统计数据：在接下来的八年里，即从1945年开始，FBI产生了长达一千页的关于奥本海默的窃听记录、文字记录和报告。
when we were talking the first episode about physics in the 1920s, and we said that it was a young man's game, and he's not a young man anymore. You know, he's, what is he, in his 40s? He's been doing a lot of bureaucratic infighting.
他们永远无法证明他曾是共产党成员，也永远无法证明他仍然是共产党人或诸如此类的东西，但这从未消失。多米尼克，这大概是因为苏联确实拥有了原子弹，而且比美国情报部门预期的要早得多，这加速了这种局势吧？是的，他们在1949年8月拥有了原子弹，他们在哈萨克斯坦进行了第一次试验。所以他们在1949年8月拥有了原子弹，他们在哈萨克斯坦进行了第一次试验。所以他们怀疑有美国共产党人的协助。好吧，他们没猜错，确实有人这么做。克劳斯·福克斯是最著名的那个，他是英国人……他是被派去协助曼哈顿计划的英国科学家之一，他在去新墨西哥州之前，甚至在英国时就已经在向苏联传递秘密了。
I like to think of that as quite young. You think of that as young? Yes, well, I know exactly what you mean. But, you know, if there's some brilliant 22-year-old physicist
所以多疑的心态可以解释那种对奥本海默的强迫性焦虑。哦，绝对可以，绝对可以，汤姆。因为如果你仔细梳理一下时间线，首先，你会发现东欧发生的所有事情。非共产党政权（如波兰、捷克斯洛伐克、匈牙利等地的政权）的被推翻，斯大林主义政权的建立，然后，当然还有柏林发生的事件以及东德的创建等等。美国也发生了一系列事件。所以我们有了针对好莱坞共产党人的听证会，我们在里根的那几集里谈到过。1948年的阿尔杰·希斯案，当时发现一名高级外交官很可能是共产间谍。还有美国人眼中的“失去中国”——1949年中国共产党取得胜利。同样是在1949年，由国会众议院成立的非美活动调查委员会（HUAC）开始调查伯克利的辐射实验室。这是他们开始调查的地方之一。你知道吗？我们总是讲述的故事——完全可以理解——是这是一种歇斯底里，是一场政治迫害，诸如此类。但斯大林主义对民主世界构成了威胁，间谍案的调查……克劳斯·福克斯就是最著名的那个。所以，当然，其中有很大剂量的歇斯底里和偏执，但其中往往也包含着一丝真相。
coming up with discoveries i mean oppenheimer is yes to them oppenheimer is yesterday's man he's an establishment man as well you know he's a symbol of corporate america and the military industrial yeah yeah absolutely but i mean the one thing that we can't underestimate i think we said that in the last episode that he'd been under surveillance by the fbi and by US Army intelligence people. That never stops. So just weeks after he's had that calamitous meeting with Harry Truman, J. Edgar Hoover sends a summary of his FBI file to Truman, and he says, we're pretty sure that he was a communist member. There's actually no evidence of that, but they say that. And they say, we also think he still has contacts with the Communist Party. And there's an amazing statistic that in the next eight years from 1945, the FBI generated a thousand pages of wiretaps, transcripts, reports on Oppenheimer.
好的。那奥本海默身上也有真相吗？我的意思是，开始围绕他的那些怀疑在多大程度上是合理的？这是一个很难回答的问题，汤姆。这是本集的核心问题。正如我们上次所看到的，他曾与共产党人交往过。他曾是一个非常非常热心的同路人。我的意思是，他自己就用过这个词来形容自己。他会说“我曾是个同路人”。他依然娶着他那个暴脾气妻子。也就是吉蒂。
They can never prove that he was a communist member they can never prove that he's still a communist or anything like that but it never goes away presumably Dominic this is expedited by the fact that the Soviet Union does get the atom bomb and gets it much sooner than American intelligence had anticipated that they would yes so they got it in August 1949 their their first test in Kazakhstan and so they got it in august 1949 their their first test in kazakhstan and so they suspect american communist help in that well they're not wrong there are people klaus fuchs is the most famous one he was british uh he was part of the british scientists that were sent to help with the manhattan project and he is sending secrets to the soviet union had been from Britain even before he went to New Mexico.
嫁给了艾米莉·布朗特。她不是……我的意思是，她把所有时间都花在躺在床上酗酒上。这就是她做的事。所以她是个资本家。是的，抽烟喝酒。人们总是说她手里叼着烟卷就睡着了。但弗洛伦斯·皮尤，她这个时候又出场了吗？没有，弗洛伦斯·皮尤不幸已经去世了。
So the mood of paranoia would explain that obsessive anxiety about Oppenheimer. Oh, absolutely. Absolutely, Tom. Because if you actually go through the chronology, first of all, you've got all the stuff in Eastern Europe. The toppling of non-communist regimes, such as they were in Poland, Czechoslovakia, Hungary, and all these places, the installation of Stalinist regimes, and then, of course, what happens in Berlin and the creation of East Germany and so on and so forth. You also have a series of incidents in the United States. So we have the hearings into communists in Hollywood, which we talked about in the Reagan episodes. The Al Juhis case in 1948, when it turns out that a senior diplomat may well have been a communist spy. There's what Americans perceive as the loss of China to the victory of
哦，好吧。那是琴·塔特洛克。但她是个共产党员。她是个共产党员，一个非常热心的共产党员。她已经结束了自己的生命。她是一个饱受困扰的人，所以她已经出局了。他没有跟共产党特工鬼混或诸如此类的事情。事实上，奥本海默在离开洛斯阿拉莫斯后，从长远来看……
the communists in China in 1949. And it's 1949 also that HUAC, the House Committee on Un-American Activities, set up by the House of Representatives in Congress, that they start investigating the radiation laboratory in Berkeley. It's one of the places they start looking at. And you know what? The story we always tell, completely understandably, is that this is hysteria, it is a witch hunt, all of this kind of stuff. But Stalinism is a threat to the democratic world and the work on the spies. So Klaus Fuchs is the most famous one. So of course, there's a huge dose of hysteria and paranoia, but there's often a little kernel of truth.
他成为了普林斯顿高等研究院的院长，正如你所知道的，汤姆，这是一个声誉极高的常春藤盟校机构。而且它既有人文学科，也有科学，对吧？所以他也在筹办这个。他不是筹办者。它已经存在了，但他成为了院长。而且他是一个非常积极的院长。
Okay. And is there a kernel of truth with Oppenheimer? I mean, to what extent are the suspicions that start to cloud around him justified? That is a tough question to answer, Tom. It's the key question of this episode. He had, as we saw last time, associated with communists. He had been a very, very keen fellow traveller. I mean, he used that expression himself, of himself. He would say I was a fellow traveller. He's still married to his Spitfire wife. It's a kitty.
他聘请人们来谈论法国诗歌。他聘请了T·S·艾略特，对吧？是的，T·S·艾略特，结果……每个人都说T·S·艾略特到了那里简直是一场彻底的灾难。那是T·S·艾略特吗？有点在嘟囔。是的。所以他来到了高等研究院。现在，这里有一个转折，因为基本上招募他的那个人——
To Emily Blunt. She's not, I mean, she spends all her time lying in bed drinking. That's what she's doing. So she's a capitalist. Yeah. Smoking and drinking. People would always say she fell asleep with a fag in her hand. But Florence Pugh, is she back on the scene at this point? No, Florence Pugh, unfortunately, is dead.
他是普林斯顿这个研究所的理事之一，名叫刘易斯……好吧，拼写是Lewis Strauss，但他总是发音为刘易斯·斯特劳斯（Lewis Straws）。我会解释原因。他来自西弗吉尼亚州。他也是德裔犹太血统。但在一个仍然相当反犹的世界里为了淡化他的犹太身份，
Oh, okay. So that's Jean Tatlock. But she was a communist. She was a communist, very keen communist. She has taken her own life. She was a very troubled person, and so she's out of the picture. He is not hobnobbing with communist agents or anything like that. In fact, what he did after leaving Los Alamos in the long run,
他把它发音为“斯特劳斯”（straws），因为他觉得这样听起来更像南方人，不那么像犹太人。现在，“斯特劳斯”（我们只能这么叫他，顺便说一句，大家都觉得这很荒谬，所以人们嘲笑他），但我们得这么叫他。他是一个非凡的人。他是白手起家的百万富翁。他最初是个巡回鞋类推销员，然后在21岁左右，
he becomes the director of the Institute of Advanced Study at Princeton, which, as you will know, Tom, is an incredibly prestigious establishment, Ivy League. And it's for humanities as well as for sciences, right? So he's setting that up as well. He's not setting it up. It already exists, but he becomes the director. And he's a very active director.
他成为了赫伯特·胡佛的助手，当时赫伯特·胡佛在第一次世界大战结束时负责对比利时的战争救援。他只是随同前往并充当志愿者。哦，我明白了。有他的照片，你知道，看起来……并不是他作为鞋类推销员的专业知识吸引了胡佛的注意。不是的。所以他穿着蝴蝶结领结到处闲逛，看起来非常具有20世纪20年代的风格。然后他跟着胡佛回来了。通过胡佛的人脉，他成为了一名华尔街投资银行家、百万富翁，以及华盛顿建制派的核心人物，
He is employing people to come and talk about French poetry. He employs T.S. Eliot, doesn't he? Yes, T.S. Eliot, who turned out, everyone said T.S. Eliot was a total disaster when he got there. Was that T.S. Eliot? Kind of mutters. Yeah. So he gets to the Institute of Advanced Studying. Now, there is a twist to this, because the guy who basically recruits him,
乡村俱乐部。是的，有点像。不过当然，那时候的许多乡村俱乐部是不欢迎犹太会员的。是的，但他叫斯特劳斯，所以大家都以为他是南方绅士。
who's one of the trustees of this institute in Princeton, is a man called Lewis. Well, it's spelt Lewis Strauss, but he always pronounces it Lewis Straws. I would explain why. He's from West Virginia. He is also of German Jewish stock. But to downplay his Jewishness in a world that is still quite anti-Semitic,
他是一个刻薄的人。他极其冷酷无情。他非常喜欢争论。他是一个不可调和的敌人。他把奥本海默弄到了普林斯顿，然后他们几乎立刻就闹翻了。而这场宿怨……
he pronounces it straws because he kind of thinks it'll sound more southern and less Jewish. Now, straws, as we have to call him, everybody thought this was ridiculous, by the way, so people laughed at him about this, but we'll have to stick with it. He is an extraordinary man. He's a self-made millionaire. He'd begun as a traveling shoe salesman then at the age of about 21 he'd become
听起来像是一些微不足道的小事，比如雇佣诗人、预定研讨室。高桌晚宴上喝什么酒。对吧。荒谬的事情。但正如我们所知，
an assistant to herbert hoover when herbert hoover was in charge of war relief for belgians at the end of the first world war he just kind of went along and volunteered oh i see and there's photos of him you know looking it wasn't kind of his his expertise as a shoe salesman had attracted Hoover's attention. No. So he was sort of swanning around in a bow tie looking very 1920s. Then he came back with Hoover. Through Hoover's contacts, he became a Wall Street investment banker, a millionaire, and a key establishment,
这类学术宿怨可能会具有难以置信的破坏性。是基辛格说过那句话吗……？是的，因为赌注太小，所以竞争才如此恶毒。但奥本海默面临的问题是，斯特劳斯是原子能委员会的成员，而且他与华盛顿的大权在握者非常亲近。事实上，他就是其中之一。他不是你想树敌的那种人。
an absolutely central kind of Washington establishment figure. Country club. Yeah, a bit. Well, although, of course, lots of country clubs in those days would not have been happy having Jewish members. Yeah, but he's called Strauss, so they all think he's a southern gentleman.
奥本海默到这个时候在社交上变得更圆滑了一点，还是他依然那种会掐死宣布自己要结婚的人的家伙？不，掐脖子的事已经成为过去了，我觉得可以这么说。掐脖子和色情诗——那些可疑的色情诗，他都已经把这些抛在脑后了。没错，因为他在管理这个研究所。但他现在能进行对话了。事实上，他甚至能与T·S·艾略特对话。但在20世纪40年代末期，
He is an abrasive man. He is utterly ruthless. He is very disputatious. He is an implacable enemy. And he gets Oppenheimer to Princeton and then they fall out almost immediately. And this feud,
有一个关于亨利·詹姆斯的传说，里面有一个家伙——我记不清叫什么名字了——他对此着迷。它叫《丛林里的野兽》。讲的是一个人经历了生活，他觉得有一种隐约的恐惧感一直跟着他。奥本海默对这个故事着迷，这并不奇怪，因为他知道他过去有些事情——共产主义的交往，即使不是党籍——可能会重新浮出水面来吞噬他。好吧。当他和斯特劳斯发生宿怨时，
which sounds like pitiful things, hiring poets, the booking of seminar rooms. What kind of wine to have at high table. Right. Ludicrous things. But as we know,
他感到了这种悬在头顶的阴影，这有一个很好的证明。事情发生在大约1949年。所以这是1949年6月发生的事情。我刚才说过，众议院非美活动调查委员会（HUAC）正在调查伯克利的实验室。他们调查的对象之一，
these kind of academic feuds can be unbelievably destructive. Was it Kissinger who said that about? Yes, because the stakes are so small that the rivalries are so venomous. But the problem for Oppenheimer is that Strauss is a member of the Atomic Energy Commission, and he is very close to the big power breakers in Washington. In fact, he's one of them. He is not a person you want to make as an enemy.
是他的弟弟弗兰克，这也是一位极具才华的物理学家，而且是一个公开的共产党员。弗兰克加入了党。那是听证会的一天。弗兰克去了，他和妻子决定：我不会撒谎。他们问他：“你曾是共产党成员吗？”他说：“是的。”他们问他：“你能告诉我们其他也是成员的科学家的名字吗？”他说：“不，我不会这么做。我不会供出别人的名字。我承认我自己的事。”他走出了听证会。
Has Oppenheimer by this point become a little bit more socially adept, or is he still the kind of guy who strangles people if they announce that they're getting married? No, the strangling is in the past, I think it's fair to say. The strangling and the erotic poetry, the dubious erotic poetry, he's left all that behind. Exactly, because he's running this institute. But he can hold a conversation now. He can hold a conversation with T.S. Eliot, in fact. But there is a sense, even in the very end of the 1940s,
在听证会结束后的一个小时内，他被明尼苏达大学解雇了。而且他再也找不到物理学的工作了，尽管他才华横溢。他在科罗拉多州当了10年的养牛场主。这就是威胁。这就是——如果这不是《历史其余部分》中最可怕的陈词滥调的话——达摩克利斯之剑，汤姆。
that there's a story about Henry James in which a guy, I can't remember what it's called, he was obsessed with it. It was called The Beast in the Jungle. And it's this guy who goes through life and he he thinks there's this he has a sense of looming dread that follows him Oppenheimer was obsessed by this story and no wonder because he knows that there are things in his past the communist associations if not membership that perhaps will re-emerge to devour him okay and. And when he has the feud with straws,
我想，积极的一面至少在于他们在骑马方面有很多练习。所以他实际上作为一个养牛场主会相当不错。我的意思是，我知道……如果你早点有他们……
he has a sense of this hanging over him and there's a really good demonstration of this. So it comes, we've got to about 1949. So it's something that happens in June 1949. I said that the HUAC, the Un-American Activities Committee, were investigating the laboratory in Berkeley. One of the people they investigate
来安慰奥本海默一家就好了。但在某种意义上，在我看来，这是奥本海默性格中最令人惊讶的一个方面：他实际上是个牛仔。好吧，我的意思是，一个临时的牛仔。他非常擅长骑马之类的一切。
is his brother, Frank, also a very talented physicist, who is a car-carrying communist. Frank had joined the party. It's a day of hearings. Frank goes along and he's decided with his wife, I'm not going to lie. They say to him, were you a member of the Communist Party? He says, yes. They say to him, will you tell us the names of the other scientists who are members? He says, nope, that's not what I'm about. I'm not going to name names. I'll admit myself. He emerges from the hearing.
一个暑假牛仔。总之，这暂且不表。所以，风险在于他可能会被踢出普林斯顿。会发生那种事吗？不。嗯，不太可能。我的意思是，那是有可能的。更有可能的是，他基本上会被政府宣布为不受欢迎的人，而这才是真正的威胁。现在他在刘易斯·斯特劳斯那里树了敌，而斯特劳斯是原子能委员会的人，这是一个不断升级的威胁。
Within an hour of the hearing ending, he has been fired by the University of Minnesota. And he couldn't get another job as a physicist, even though he was brilliant. And he spent the next 10 years as a cattle rancher in Colorado. So that is the threat. That is, as it were, if it's not the most hideous cliche ever in the rest of history, the sword of Damocles, Tom.
同时斯特劳斯也是他在普林斯顿的顶头上司……是的，而且恨透了他。关键在于，斯特劳斯是氢弹的超级大粉丝，所以他想要威力更大的炸弹。他还想要绝对的保密。他鄙视所有那些分享、善良以及过度杀死数百万人的行径。对吧，他根本容不下这些。
I mean, I suppose the positive would be that at least they have all their practice on horse riding. So he'd actually be quite good as a cattle rancher. I mean, I know that... If only they'd had you
那是共产主义的废话。好吧，斯特劳斯真心实意地开始相信——毫无疑问地——他真心实意地认为奥本海默是一个共产党特工。而这，当然就是将要打倒奥本海默的原因。让我们休息一下，看看当斯特劳斯打倒奥本海默的决心开始发挥作用时会发生什么。几分钟后见。
to console them, the Oppenheimers. But there is a sense in which that is, to me, the most surprising aspect of Oppenheimers. But there is a sense in which that is, to me, the most surprising aspect of Oppenheimer's character is that he was effectively a cowboy. Well, I mean, a temporary cowboy. He's very good at horse riding and all that.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。开始发挥作用时会发生什么。几分钟后见。想要获取现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。多米尼克，我们正在聊奥本海默的职业生涯。原子弹已经爆炸。他离开了洛斯阿拉莫斯。他在普林斯顿与刘易斯·斯特劳斯共事，而他们相处得并不融洽。这对奥本海默很不利，因为斯特劳斯怀疑奥本海默是个共产主义分子。
A summer holiday cowboy. Anyway, that's by the by. So, the risk is that he might be chucked out of Princeton. Would that happen? No. Well, unlikely. I mean, that's possible. More likely is that he will basically be declared persona non grata by the by the government and that is the real threat and now that he has made this enemy in lewis straws who is the guy on the atomic energy commission that is an escalating
一个暑假牛仔。不管怎样，那都是题外话。所以，风险在于他可能会被普林斯顿大学开除。会发生这种事吗？不会。嗯，不太可能。我的意思是，那是有可能的。更有可能的是，他基本上会被政府宣布为不受欢迎的人，这才是真正的威胁，现在他已经在原子能委员会的刘易斯·斯特劳斯那里树敌，后者是一个不断升级的
threat who is also his basically his boss at princeton yeah and who hates him absolutely and it's crucially Strauss is a big big fan of the H-bomb so he wants bigger bombs he also wants total secrecy he despises all this stuff
威胁，基本上也是他在普林斯顿的上司，是的，而且他绝对恨他。关键在于，斯特劳斯是氢弹的超级狂热粉丝，所以他想要威力更大的炸弹，他也想要绝对的机密，他鄙视所有这些
of sharing and kindness and over killing millions of people right he has no time for any of this
分享、善良以及过度消灭数百万人的那一套，对吧？他对这些毫无兴趣
that's commie rot well he genuinely Strauss comes to believe without any shadow of a doubt he genuinely thinks this that Oppenheimer is a communist agent. And this, of course, is what's going to bring Oppenheimer down. Let's take a break and find out what happens when Strauss's determination to bring Oppenheimer down starts to work itself out. See you back in a few minutes.
那是共产党的废话。嗯，斯特劳斯真心实意地、毫无疑问地相信——他是真的这么想的——奥本海默是一名共产党特工。当然，这正是将导致奥本海默垮台的原因。我们休息一下，看看当斯特劳斯决心打倒奥本海默的计划开始发挥作用时会发生什么。几分钟后见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. starts to work itself out. See you back in a few minutes. early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. So, Dominic, we are talking the career of Oppenheimer. The atom bombs have gone off. He has left Los Alamos. He is at Princeton with Lewis Straws, and they're not getting on. And this is bad for Oppenheimer because Strauss suspects Oppenheimer of being a commie.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐秘史》。开始发挥作用时会发生什么。几分钟后见。想要提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史秘史》。所以，多米尼克，我们正在讨论奥本海默的职业生涯。原子弹已经爆炸。他已经离开洛斯阿拉莫斯。他在普林斯顿与刘易斯·斯特劳斯在一起，他们相处得并不融洽。这对奥本海默来说很糟糕，因为斯特劳斯怀疑奥本海默是个共产党。
Right. Exactly. And Strauss is not alone. So about 1952, Oppenheimer's doing his thing, arranging people to come and give talks at Princeton, but he is still a consultant to the Atomic Energy Commission. So's a celebrity. He is an important public figure who delivers speeches about atomic diplomacy, about a democrat called william l borden so this is not all directed by the way by the hard right um and borden he too is a fervent advocate of the hydrogen bomb and says we need bigger better bombs to win the cold war but he is also he knows that oppenheimer has gone around washington saying hydrogen bombs are a bad idea. And Borden starts writing to people across Washington and saying, I think Oppenheimer is saying this because he's a communist. I genuinely think he is a Soviet agent and Stalin is directing him to oppose the atom bomb. And because he's so influential, this is a serious issue. And then the third part of this sort of triumvirate, I mean, you've. edgar hoover as well at the fbi who thinks basically thinks everybody's a communist
对。确实。施特劳斯并不孤单。大约在1952年，奥本海默在忙着安排人到普林斯顿做演讲，但他依然是原子能委员会的顾问。所以他是个名人。他是一个重要的公众人物，发表关于原子外交、关于一个叫威廉·L·博登的民主党人的演讲——顺便说一句，这并非全部由极右翼指使，嗯——博登他也坚决主张制造氢弹，并表示我们需要更大更好的炸弹来赢得冷战，但他也知道奥本海默曾在华盛顿到处说氢弹是个坏主意。博登开始写信给华盛顿各界人士，称我认为奥本海默这么说是因为他是名共产主义者。我真心认为他是苏联特工，斯大林正指使他反对原子弹。由于他极具影响力，这是一个严重的问题。然后是这个所谓三人同盟的第三部分，我的意思是，还有……埃德加·胡佛，他在FBI也基本上认为每个人都是共产主义者
and is this guy edward teller oh yes dr strange love oppenheimer's former colleague who is passionate about the h-bomb it's his own personal project so this is his own his baby ticket to celebrity and he is horrified that the super as they call it, is being blocked by Oppenheimer. And he explicitly tells the FBI in 1951, he says, I will do anything possible to see Oppenheimer's relationship with the government terminated. In other words, no, it loses security clearance. That's it. Thrown off all the atomic boards, all that kind of thing. That's exactly it. So the big provocation comes on the 17th of February, 1953. Oppenheimer gives a lecture to the Council on Foreign
而这个人就是爱德华·泰勒？哦，是的，奇爱博士，奥本海默的前同事，他对氢弹充满热情，这是他个人的项目。所以这是他自己的亲生骨肉，是他通往名望的敲门砖。他惊恐地发现，被他们称为“超级炸弹”的项目正遭到奥本海默的阻挠。他在1951年明确告诉FBI，他说，我将不惜一切代价促使奥本海默与政府的关系终结。换句话说，不，他失去了安全许可。就是这样。被踢出所有原子能委员会，诸如此类的事情。完全是这样。所以最大的挑衅发生在1953年2月17日。奥本海默在外交关系
Relations. So some of our listeners will know this is a real gathering place of the great and the good of the American establishment. Lewis Straws, by the way, is in the audience for this. And Oppenheimer gives this lecture and he says, the age of secrecy about atomic weapons must come to an end. We must stop covering up what we have and what we know about their repercussions. We must be honest for the first time with the American people and tell them that we cannot fight and win a nuclear war, that the repercussions would be far too grave. He has this image. He says, we in the Soviet Union are like two scorpions in a bottle. Each is capable of killing the other, but only at the cost of his own life. Now,
协会发表了一场演讲。因此，我们的一些听众会知道，这是美国政治建制派中精英和名流真正的聚集地。顺便说一句，刘易斯·施特劳斯也在台下听讲。奥本海默发表了这篇演讲，他说，关于原子武器的秘密时代必须结束了。我们必须停止掩盖我们所拥有的以及我们对它们后果的了解。我们必须第一次对美国人民诚实，告诉他们我们无法打赢一场核战争，因为其后果将过于严重。他用了这样一个意象。他说，我们和苏联就像瓶子里的两只蝎子。每一只都有能力杀死对方，但代价仅仅是自己的生命。现在，
lots of people in his audience think this is actually very sensible stuff. This is completely reasonable. But the thing is, there's a new administration in town, the Eisenhower administration. So the Secretary of State, John Foster Dulles, he is committed to a doctrine called massive retaliation. And that basically is, if the Soviet Union overstepped the mark, we will bomb them with nuclear weapons and absolutely destroy them. Bomb them back to the Stone Age. It's a very, very hawkish position. But slightly counterintuitively, the former general and now president, Dwight D. Eisenhower, is a bit ambivalent about this. So Eisenhower actually had had doubts about whether bombing Hiroshima and Nagasaki was the right thing to do.
台下的许多人认为这实际上是非常明智的观点。这完全合情合理。但问题是，新政府上台了，也就是艾森豪威尔政府。所以国务卿约翰·福斯特·杜勒斯，他致力于一项名为“大规模报复”的原则。这基本上就是，如果苏联越界，我们将用核武器轰炸他们并彻底摧毁他们。把他们炸回石器时代。这是一个非常非常强硬的立场。但略带反直觉的是，前将军、现任总统德怀特·D·艾森豪威尔对此有点矛盾。所以艾森豪威尔实际上曾对轰炸广岛和长崎是否是正确的做法产生过怀疑。
Well, I suppose military men know what war means. Exactly. I think that's right. Military men are often more sensible than gung-ho civilians. And Lewis Straws is terrified that Eisenhower will agree with Oppenheimer. He thinks Eisenhower will listen to this and be seduced by it. So Straws contacts the FBI and he contacts the White House and he says, Oppenheimer, my colleague at Princeton, is a commie, is a communist. He's a Soviet agent. The administration should distance themselves from him.
嗯，我想军人知道战争意味着什么。确实。我认为是这样的。军人往往比盲目好战的平民更明智。刘易斯·施特劳斯吓坏了，担心艾森豪威尔会同意奥本海默的观点。他认为艾森豪威尔会听进去并被其蛊惑。于是施特劳斯联系了FBI，并联系了白宫，他说，奥本海默，我在普林斯顿的同事，是个赤化分子，是个共产主义者。他是苏联特工。政府应该与他保持距离。
And all that he is saying is inspired by Moscow. And then Oppenheimer makes another of these catastrophic mistakes that he keeps on making. Later that year, Tom, he goes to Europe because he's been invited to give the Reith Lectures. Oh, to the BBC. As our British listeners will know, these are these very prestigious lectures that the BBC organise every year. They will choose a kind of Nobel Prize winner or
他所说的一切都是受莫斯科启发。然后奥本海默又犯了那种他一再犯下的灾难性错误。同年晚些时候，汤姆，他去了欧洲，因为他受邀去发表里思讲座。哦，去BBC。正如我们英国听众所知道的那样，这是BBC每年组织的高声望讲座。他们会选择诺贝尔奖得主或者
an absolute... Although Oppenheimer never gets the Nobel Prize, does he? No, he doesn't. He doesn't. He could well have done if he hadn't got involved with the... you know, if his career hadn't taken that extraordinary twist. Oppenheimer's come to give the Reith Lectures, these very prestigious lectures, and while he's in Europe, he goes
绝对是……尽管奥本海默从未获得诺贝尔奖，对吧？不，他没有。他没有。如果他没有卷入……你知道的，如果他的职业生涯没有经历那种非同寻常的转折，他本可以得奖的。奥本海默来到这里发表里思讲座，这些极具声望的演讲，当他在欧洲时，他去了
to Paris, and he has dinner with Horkin Chevalier, the bloke who had tried to... The professor of medieval French poetry. Right, who had been the communist kind of intermediary. Now, on one level, you could say, what an admirable act of friendship. On the other hand,
巴黎，并与霍金·谢瓦利埃共进晚餐，就是那个曾试图……那个中世纪法国诗歌教授。对，就是那个曾充当共产主义中间人的人。现在，从某种程度上讲，你可以说，多么令人钦佩的友谊之举啊。另一方面，
what a disaster, because Strauss has had the US embassy tail Oppenheimer through Paris and log all his phone calls, so they know that he's doing this. And actually, this story is always told, by the way, Oppenheimer the martyr, Strauss an absolute monster and a madman. But if you were to take Strauss' side just for a moment, Oppenheimer is giving them a lot of ammo. He did flirt with communism. he was a fellow traveler now he's going and having dinner with
简直是一场灾难，因为施特劳斯让美国驻巴黎大使馆一路跟踪奥本海默并记录了他所有的电话，所以他们知道他在这么做。实际上，这个故事总是被讲述为：奥本海默是烈士，施特劳斯是个彻头彻尾的怪物和疯子。但如果你哪怕只站一会儿施特劳斯的立场，奥本海默确实给了他们很多弹药。他确实调情过共产主义，他曾是个同路人，现在他又去跟
this one of his old communist buddies so what is the status of the the french professor he's just a professor of french so he's still he hasn't been sacked or anything he hasn't been fingered as a communist i don't think has he i think he has i think he's openly a communist but i don't think there have been great repercussions for him okay and so it's at that point that the fbi say to eisenhower listen you must absolutely cut off all your contacts with this guy and by the end of the year senior eisenhower administration people are meeting straws and they're saying listen okay fine we need to act against oppenheimer and make an example of him it's the making example the public nature of it that that i think makes this case resonate because they decide that the way to
他的一位老共产党同伙共进晚餐。那么那个法国教授的现状如何？他只是个法语教授，所以他还是……他没有被解雇或怎样，他也没有被指认是一个共产党人，我想他没有吧？我想他有，我认为他公开自己是共产党人，但我认为这并没有给他带来太大的恶劣影响。好吧，正是在那个时候，FBI对艾森豪威尔说，听着，你必须彻底切断与这家伙的所有联系。到了年底，艾森豪威尔政府的高级官员与施特劳斯会面，他们说，听着，好吧，我们需要对奥本海默采取行动，杀一儆百。正是这种杀一儆百、公开性质的做法，我认为让这个案件产生共鸣，因为他们决定采取的方式
do this is to hold this review of his security clearance um his security clearance will be suspended but he can appeal and in a way i think straws kind of wants him to appeal because if he appeals then they'll hold hearings which will be publicly reported and the hearings will effectively be a trial so oppenheimer will go on trial so slight shades here of of our previous episodes on oscar wilde a figure whose trial has vast kind of cultural resonances yeah it's not just you know it's not just oppenheimer it's a whole cast of thought that is being put on trial that is that is quite right tom it is a whole cast of thought that is put on trial because by this point, McCarthyism is kind of at its height. So Joe McCarthy, Senator from Wisconsin, had given a speech in February 1950 in Wheeling, West Virginia to a group of Republican women where he had said, I have in my hand a list of 205 communists working in the State Department. This was complete balderdash, by the way.
是举办这场针对他安全许可的审查，嗯，他的安全许可将被暂停，但他可以上诉。在某种程度上，我想施特劳斯某种程度上希望他上诉，因为如果他上诉，他们就会举行听证会，而这些听证会将公开报道，听证会实际上将成为一场审判。所以奥本海默将面临审判。这里有点我们之前关于王尔德的剧集的影子，王尔德这个人物的审判在文化上产生了深远的影响。是的，这不仅仅是——你知道的——不仅仅是奥本海默，而是一种被推上审判台的思想流派，完全是这样的，汤姆，这是一种被推上审判台的思想流派，因为到这个时候，麦卡锡主义已经达到了顶峰。所以约瑟夫·麦卡锡，威斯康星州参议员，于1950年2月在西弗吉尼亚州惠灵向一群共和党妇女发表了一次演讲，他在演讲中说：我手里有一份在国务院工作的205名共产党人的名单。顺便说一句，这完全是胡说八道。
And from that point onwards, there had been this climate of hysterical paranoia about communists and about fellow travelers. And basically, if you'd been in a room near a book that mentioned Karl Marx, you were fair game. And particularly in universities, it's used as an excuse to kind of purge people for particularly the kind of the old guard who had been flirting with ideas to the left of the New Deal in the 1930s. The Republicans use it as a way of attacking the Democrats and the democratic establishment who had run United States politics from 1933 all the way through to the beginning of the 1950s.
从那时起，就弥漫着一种对共产主义者和同路人的歇斯底里偏执气氛。基本上，如果你曾身处一本提到卡尔·马克思的书附近的房间里，你就是众矢之的。特别是在大学里，它被用作一种借口，用来清洗人们，特别是那些在20世纪30年代曾对新政左翼思想产生过好感的守旧派。共和党人将其作为攻击民主党人和自1933年一直统治到20世纪50年代初的民主党建制派的一种方式。
So there's all kinds of different things going on. And in the middle of all this, Oppenheimer, who, you know, he's a physicist, not normally celebrities, but he's the father of the bomb. He's the face of the atom bomb. For him to be caught up in this makes it this incredibly kind of totemic showdown. And so he says he's going to appeal it. Of course, everybody knew that he would.
所以各种各样的事情都在发生。而在这一切的中心，奥本海默，你知道的，他是一名物理学家，通常不是什么名人，但他却是炸弹之父，是原子弹的代名词。他被卷入其中，使得这变成了一场极其具有图腾意义的摊牌。因此他说他要上诉。当然，每个人都知道他会这么做。
And we were in Washington a couple of weeks ago, Tom. We were by the Washington Monument. There's a building not far from the Washington Monument, one of many buildings that had been put up in a rush during World War II because Washington bureaucracy was expanding because of the burdens of first the New Deal and then the war. So on the 12th of April, the hearings open in this building. So there's a review board. There are basically three judges. Strauss has picked them himself. He's handpicked them. Two conservative Democrats and one conservative Republican. And for a month, the trial lasts for a month. I say trial, it's a hearing. And it's all public. Well, it's reported in the newspaper. So it's a front page story in
我们几周前在华盛顿，汤姆。我们在华盛顿纪念碑附近。华盛顿纪念碑不远有一座建筑，这是二战期间由于华盛顿官僚机构因首先是新政、然后是战争的负担而膨胀，从而仓促修建的众多建筑之一。所以在4月12日，听证会在大楼里开庭了。所以有一个审查委员会。基本上有三名法官。施特劳斯亲自挑选了他们。他是精挑细选的。两名保守派民主党人和一名保守派共和党人。持续了一个月，审判持续了一个月。我说审判，这是一场听证会。而且全部是公开的。嗯，报纸上有报道。所以它是《纽约时报》头版的故事。我的意思是，我不认为这是那种人们排队买票抢座之类的事情。它没有被电视转播。不，没有电视转播或类似的东西。毫无疑问，奥本海默正在接受审判。他被指控是共产主义外围组织的成员。他被指控与共产主义特工交往。他还被指控在洛斯阿拉莫斯雇用共产党人。实际上，在某种程度上，这件事滑稽的地方在于所有这些事情都是真的。他确实是。他曾是个同路人。
the New York Times. I mean, I don't think it's this kind of thing where you've got crowds of people, you know, queuing for seats or anything like that. It's not televised. No, it's not televised or anything like that. And there's no doubt that Oppenheimer is on trial. He's accused of being a member of communist front organizations. He's accused of associating with communist agents. And he's accused of employing communists at Los Alamos. And actually, to some extent, I mean, the funny thing about this is all those things are true. He did. He was a fellow traveler.
他确实与共产党人交游甚密。洛斯阿拉莫斯的一些人确实有非常激进的同情倾向。但终极问题难道不是：他是个叛徒吗？而他不是。我的意思是，难道这不是核心问题吗？是的。嗯，当然，你完全说得对。因为基本上，我的意思是，如果你是个共产党人或同路人什么的，
He did hobnob with communists. And some of the people at Los Alamos did have very radical sympathies. But surely the ultimate question is, is he a traitor? And he's not. I mean, isn't that the question? Yeah. Well, of course, you're absolutely right. Because basically, I mean, if you're a communist or a communist or whatever,
但你不是叛徒，那其实就没关系。嗯，这是他的支持者们所说的。所以格罗夫斯将军，他以前是个上校，现在是将军了。当年在洛斯阿拉莫斯雇佣他的人，顺便说一句，是一个非常保守的人。他去出席听证会并表示，我不在乎奥本海默是不是同路人。我对他的爱国主义没有任何怀疑。我对他的国家服务没有任何怀疑。我不认为他是安全风险。这就是许多人所说的。当然，奥本海默在20世纪
but you're not a traitor, then it doesn't really matter. Well, this is what his supporters say. So General Groves, he was a colonel, now he's general. The guy who had hired him at Los Alamos, who is, by the way, a very conservative man. He goes to the hearings and he says, I didn't care that Oppenheimer was a fellow traveler. I had no doubts about his patriotism. I had no doubts about his service to the nation. I didn't think he was a security risk. And this is what a lot of people say. Sure, Oppenheimer associated with communists in the
30年代与共产党人交往过，但很多人都这样做过。对于他对国家的忠诚从来没有任何怀疑。从来没有迹象表明他是不可信赖的。我认为这也是真的。人们认为他有风险是可以理解的。但当你深入调查时，没有任何丝毫怀疑表明他除了对美国绝对忠诚之外还有其他任何身份。但这对于奥本海默来说是极大的羞辱。他被迫承认那些同路人的交往。他被迫承认他与
1930s, but lots of people did. There's never been any doubt about his fidelity to his country. There's never been any sense in which he was untrustworthy. And I think that that's true too. It's understandable why people thought he was a risk. But then when you look into it, there's no suspicion whatsoever that he was anything other than utterly faithful to the United States. But this is a terrible humiliation for Oppenheimer. He's forced to admit about the fellow traveling. He is forced to admit about that conversation that he had with
那个谢瓦利埃的谈话，他最初没有汇报。然后他以一种笨拙的、稍微捏造的、夸张的方式汇报了这件事。基本上被实际上充当检察官的那个人告知他是个捏造者，他编造谎言，而奥本海默并没有反驳。他说，是的，我想我确实编造了关于那次谈话的事情。最令人羞辱的是，他被迫承认自己在整个20世纪40年代初仍在与吉恩·塔特洛克、弗洛伦斯·普顿见面，尽管他已经结婚，尽管他知道她是个共产党人。
that guy Chevalier that he didn't initially report. And then he reported it in a sort of, in this ham-fisted, slightly made up, exaggerated way. He's told by basically the guy who's effectively the prosecutor that he's a fabricator, he weaves tissues of lies, and Oppenheimer doesn't disagree. He says, yeah, I suppose I did make up stuff about that conversation. And very humiliatingly, he's forced to admit that he was still seeing Gene Tatlock, Florence Puton throughout the early 1940s even though he was married, even though he knew she was a communist
所有这些对他的打击都相当大。然后在某些方面，最著名的时刻发生在4月28日，也就是听证会开始两周多之后，爱德华·泰勒，他前洛斯阿拉莫斯同事、那个一直倡导氢弹的人，走上了证人席。
that's all pretty damaging for him and then in some ways the great the famous moment comes on the 28th of April so that's more than two weeks after the hearings have been going, when Edward Teller his former Los Alamos colleague the guy who's been advocating for the hydrogen bomb, he takes the stand.
他说，他把奥本海默给出卖了。他说，当他在洛斯阿拉莫斯担任主任时，他的行为常常极其难以理解，并且给出的理由在我看来混乱而复杂。然后有人问他，你认为他的安全许可应该被撤销吗？泰勒说，我认为美国利益应该交由更可信赖的人来掌管，不予批准他的安全许可将是明智之举。现场有一种巨大的……你知道的，气氛非常紧张，这个家伙说的话。这不是什么哗然。我想这就像是一次倒吸冷气。那是一种充满紧张感的沉默。在离开时，泰勒——一个奇怪的细节。
And he says, he throws Oppenheimer under the bus. He says, when he was director at Los Alamos, he often acted in a way which was exceedingly hard to understand and gave reasons that seemed to me confused and complicated. And then he's asked, do you think his security clearance should be withdrawn? And Teller says, I think US interests should be in much more trustworthy hands and it would be wise not to grant him clearance. And there's a great kind of, you know, the atmosphere is electric that this guy caught. It's not kind of uproar. I think it's like a intake of breath. It's a silence that is fraught with tension. And on his way out, Teller, I mean, a strange detail.
当泰勒在离开时从奥本海默身边经过时，他用这种生硬的带有匈牙利口音的英语对他说，我很抱歉。他们握了握手。然后他就离开了。裁决在5月23日下达，实际上施特劳斯气急败坏，因为反对奥本海默的票数只有二比一，你敢相信吗，汤姆，那个共和党人居然支持他！哇，所以施特劳斯在玩弄阴谋手段。我的意思是这起作用了，但没有……没有如你所希望的那样全票通过。那个共和党人实际上发表了一份措辞严厉的
As Teller passes Oppenheim on the way out, he says to him in this sort of guttural Hungarian-accented English, I'm sorry. And they shake hands. And then off he goes. And the verdict comes down on the 23rd of may it's actually Strauss is livid because it was only two to one against Oppenheimer and would you believe it Tom the republican guy backed him wow so so Strauss is gerrymandering I mean it works but not not not as um unanimously as you've been hoping the republican guy actually issued a blistering
反对意见。他说，你知道的，我读了所有的材料，我听了所有的……那个共和党人实际上发表了一份措辞严厉的反对意见。他说，我读了所有这些材料。我听了所有这些材料。这里其实并没有什么FBI在1941年或1942年还不知道的新东西。他说，奥本海默，当然他有过愚蠢的交往，但人都会有。没有任何叛国证据。他最后说，这是我们国家盾徽上的一个黑点。这真是一个绝妙的短语。这也是一个非常好的短语。现在，并非所有共和党人都这样想。
dissent and he said this you know I've read all the stuff I've heard all. The Republican guy actually issued a blistering dissent. And he said, I've read all this stuff. I've heard all this stuff. There is actually nothing new here that the FBI didn't know in 1941 or 1942. He said, Oppenheimer, sure he had foolish associations, but people do. There's no evidence of any treachery. And he ends by saying, this is a black mark on the escutcheon of our country. That's a great phrase. Which is a very good phrase. Now, not all Republicans felt like that.
当裁决在众议院宣布时，一些共和党国会议员起立鼓掌。这就是20世纪50年代麦卡锡主义狂热的心态。有趣的是，那一刻既摧毁了奥本海默，又造就了奥本海默。因为一方面，当他失去安全许可时，他就彻底出局了。他被建制派抛弃了。
When the verdict was announced in the House of Representatives, some Republican congressmen stood up and applauded. Such is the mood of sort of McCarthyite fervor in the 1950s. And the funny thing is that that's a moment that simultaneously destroys and makes Oppenheimer. Because on the one hand, when he loses that security clearance, he's out. He's out of the establishment.
顺便说一句，他在普林斯顿的工作保住了。他没有失去那个。但他没有被邀请参加所有这些会议。在艾森豪威尔政府的权力大厅里，他的名字不再具有号召力。他被玷污了。那是他的终结。而且他受到了公开的羞辱。
He keeps his job at Princeton, by the way. He doesn't lose that. But he doesn't get invited to all these meetings. His is not a name to conjure with in the halls of power in the Eisenhower administration. He is tainted. That's the end of him. And he's been humiliated publicly.
然而另一方面，它塑造了一个新的奥本海默，也就是烈士。因此，人们写出了大量这种雅克风格的 essays。泰勒在许多科学家中成了过街老鼠，他们会特意绕路避开他、不跟他握手之类，不愿与他同台。刘易斯·施特劳斯，这位战胜了他伟大死敌的胜利者，成了自由派眼中痛恨的人物。
And yet, on the other hand, it creates a new Oppenheimer, which is the martyr. So people pour out all these kind of Jacques style essays. Teller becomes a pariah among lots of scientists kind of will cross the road to avoid him, not shake his hand and stuff, won't appear on panels with him. Louis Strauss, who has won this great victory over his great foe, he becomes a hate figure to liberals.
实际上，当艾森豪威尔在20世纪50年代末提名他为商务部长时，他因对待奥本海默的方式遭到参议院的否决。所以这是一场惨胜。这确实是一场惨胜，汤姆。我的意思是，奇怪的是：
And actually Eisenhower, when he nominated him as his secretary of commerce at the end of the 1950s, he was blocked by the Senate because of his treatment of Oppenheimer. So a Pyrrhic victory. It was a Pyrrhic victory, Tom. I mean, here's the weird thing.
他从未停止对奥本海默的痴迷，多年后他仍然在对奥本海默下令进行FBI窃听。哇。但对奥本海默本人来说，我的意思是，当你阅读库伯特和马丁·谢尔曼所著的那部庞大的泰坦尼克号般的传记时，这很有趣，我在这些播客中广泛引用了它。从这一点开始，故事很快就结束了，因为他们基本上说，从这一刻起，奥本海默在精神上已经死了。所以他受到了公开的羞辱，他在美属维尔京群岛的一个叫圣约翰的岛上度过了很多时间，基本上就是喝酒、抽烟、闲逛以及感到悲伤。他在写诗吗？
He never stopped being obsessed with Oppenheimer, and he was still kind of ordering FBI wiretaps on Oppenheimer years afterwards. Wow. But for Oppenheimer himself, I mean, it's interesting when you read this enormous sort of titanic biography by Kuybert and Martin Sherman, which I've quoted from extensively in these podcasts. After this point, the story just ends very quickly because they basically say that from this moment, Oppenheimer was spiritually dead. So he's been humiliated public and he spends a lot of time in the US Virgin Islands, an island called St. John, basically drinking and smoking and just hanging around and being sad. Is he writing poetry?
我想写诗的阶段已经结束了，实际上。我可能记错了。因为他以前能写出一些非常伤感的诗。这有一种讽刺意味，核时代之父变成了这样一个著名的受害者，我想，也就是烈士。事实上，他开始说，不再对自己在洛斯阿拉莫斯的作用大加赞赏并引以为豪，当他谈到、当这被提起时，他……现在，我不知道这其中有多少是他的表演成分。换句话说，
I think the writing poetry is over, actually. I might be wrong. Because he could write some very sad poems. And there's a sort of irony that the father of the nuclear age has become this very famous victim, I suppose, martyr. And in fact, he starts to say, instead of exalting about his role at Los Alamos and all that stuff and being proud of it, when he talks, when it comes up, he's... Now, I don't know whether how much this is him being performative. In other
扮演由他的自由派崇拜者为他准备好的角色。但他总是谈论自己的罪责。当他的儿子从学校毕业时，他被邀请去儿子的学校，他谈到广岛时说那是一个悲剧性的错误。你知道，诸如此类的话。因此，他作为烈士的名誉，开始与他是一个对自己所做的事感到某种程度后悔的人这种感觉交织在一起。是的。因此，他成了一个原型人物，
words, playing the part that has been prepared for him by his liberal admirers. But he always talks about his guilt. And he's invited to his son's school when his son graduates from school, and he talks about Hiroshima and says it was a tragic mistake. You know, these kinds of things. So his reputation as a martyr, it starts to elide with a sense that he is someone who regrets what he's done, to a degree. Yes. And so he comes to seem a kind of the archetypal figure
总结了人们对这项创造了炸弹的伟大科学计划的矛盾、紧张和复杂反应，以及它所释放的恐怖。是的，我想对他的支持者来说，他们喜欢赞美的那个人是一个被自己的责任感所困扰的人。我的意思是，正如我们之前所说，他不喜欢用“罪责”（guilt）这个词，但他确实使用“责任”（responsibility）这个词，这就是为什么来自《薄伽梵歌》的那句话与他如此紧密地联系在一起，即使他当时并没有真正说出口。是的，因为他说过他说过，这才是重要的一点，不是吗？他现在感觉到了这一点。是的，现在我成了死神，世界的毁灭者。我想，甚至在奥本海默听证会和反共风潮之前，早在
who sums up the paradoxes and the tensions and the complexities of responses to this great scientific program that's created the bomb, but also the horror that that has unleashed. Yeah, I think certainly for his supporters, the man they like to celebrate is a man haunted by his own responsibility. I mean, as we said before he doesn't like to use the word guilt but he does use the word responsibility and so that's the that's why that um that phrase from from the bhagavad-gita becomes so associated with him even if he didn't actually say it at the time yeah because he says he said it and that's the important thing isn't it that he feels it now yeah now i am become death the destroyer of worlds and i guess that actually even before the oppenheimer hearings and the anti-communism stuff there were people even in
1945年，甚至在那一刻，就有人对原子弹的消息感到震惊。嗯，你说有人感到恶心。是的，当消息传进来时，我的意思是物理学家，我的意思是有人在英国和美国的日记中写道，等等，有些人对超级武器感到高兴，但有些人则想，天哪，我们杀害了多少——10万？12万？——人，并对它可能导致的后果感到恐惧。是的，不仅仅是恐惧……但不仅仅是恐惧，还有一种感觉，你知道，有多少万日本妇女和儿童被那个炸弹摧毁了，即使你认为这是正确的事情，目睹这一切也不可能欢欣鼓舞，我想是的。不过也有人会。
1945 even at the very moment who were horrified by news of the atom bomb well you said people being sick yeah when the news comes in i mean physicists i mean there are people who write in their diaries in england and america and so on some who are delighted by the super weapon but some who think gosh we've killed what 100 000 people 120 000 people and dread of where it might lead yeah and the dread of well not just not just the dread though but also a sense that you know how many tens of thousands of japanese women and children were destroyed by that bomb and it's impossible to look on that and to exalt, I would say, even if you think it was the right thing to do. Well, although some do.
嗯，当他们……曾经有过一场巨大的风波。我第一次去美国时，汤姆，在20世纪90年代，华盛顿爆发了一场巨大的争论，因为史密森尼学会举办了一场关于“埃诺拉·盖伊”号的展览。许多人认为它爱国主义不够，过于自责，说得难听点，就是些“觉醒”废话。所以这是杜鲁门对阵奥本海默。嗯，杜鲁门与奥本海默的分歧，我的意思是，如果你看不出这是一个非常复杂的问题，我觉得你脑子有点毛病。
Well, when they had a, there was a massive few already. The very first time I went to America, Tom, in the 1990s, a huge row, I went to Washington and a huge row was underway in Washington because the Smithsonian had put on an exhibition about the Enola Gay. And lots of people thought it was insufficiently patriotic and too hand-wringing that it was, dare I say, woke tosh. So it's Truman against Oppenheimer. Well, that Truman-Oppenheimer divide, I mean, I think there's something wrong with you if you can't see that this is a very complicated issue.
是的，当然。当然。这就是为什么奥本海默的传记如此有趣。是的，完全如此。完全如此。他是一个非常复杂的人。顺便说一句，他在晚年稍微得到了一些平反。肯尼迪邀请他去白宫吃晚饭。然后在1963年底，LBJ授予了他一枚奖章和奖项。他的安全许可恢复了吗？从未。曾有人讨论过要恢复。
Yeah, of course. Of course. And this is why Oppenheimer's biography is so interesting. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. He's a very complicated man. By the way, he was rehabilitated a bit in the final years. Kennedy invited him to the White House for dinner. And then LBJ gave him a medal in the prize at the end of 1963. Is his security clearance restored or not? Never. There was talk of doing it.
但肯尼迪政府的人说这太具争议性了。我们应该避开。我们只需请他吃晚餐并给他一些奖品。给他一枚奖章。实际上，爱德华·泰勒，那个基本上背后捅他刀子的人，在他领奖时也在场。
But people in the Kennedy administration said it's too controversial. We should steer clear. We'll just have him for dinner and give him some prizes. Give him a medal. And actually, Edward Teller, the man who had basically stabbed him in the back, he was there when he got his prize
他们又握了握手。非常奇怪。嗯，这一切对奥本海默很有利，在此之前我们主要把他塑造成有点怪异的人。我认为这对他的形象很有利。嗯，我觉得奥本海默滑稽的地方在于，对我来说，他不是一个很讨人喜欢的人。我猜他作为一个同事会是个糟糕透顶的人，而且我无法想象能成为他的朋友。
and they shook hands again. Very strange. Well, it all reflects very well on Oppenheimer, who up till now we've chiefly been casting as a bit of a weirdo. I think that reflects well on him. Well, I think the funny thing about Oppenheimer is that, to me, he's not a very likable man. I imagine he would be a terrible person to have as a colleague, and I can't imagine being his friend.
但他是一个非凡的人物。我的意思是，聪明绝顶。除此之外，没有多少科学家能如此彻底地投身于公共事务和新闻头条之中——也许爱因斯坦算一个，但奥本海默非常了不起，你知道，不仅仅是以一种理查德·道金斯式的方式参与那些演变成公开辩论的知识分子辩论，而是一个改变历史、影响数百万人生命的人。而且再次强调，从你在我们第一集的第一部分中所说的一切来看，他听起来是那么不适合这项任务，但他却能领导这一非凡的规划壮举——
But he's an extraordinary figure. I mean, incredibly clever. And beyond that, there aren't many scientists who propel themselves so completely into the world of public affairs and into the kind of headlines maybe einstein but oppenheimer is remarkable you know not not just in a such a richard dawkins way about being involved with intellectual debates that become public debates but a man who changes history who affects the lives of of millions and again i mean he he sounds so unsuited to that task from everything that you said in the first part of our first episode that he could have been at the head of this remarkable feat of of planning that's
这就是悖论所在，不是吗？他是一个如此不适合的人，而这正是它如此吸引人的地方。这就是奥本海默。他于1967年死于癌症，他抽了一辈子烟，喝了一辈子酒。我认为是吸烟害了他。他享年62岁，一生充满了戏剧性。但他的死敌泰勒活到了100岁左右，直到20世纪末还在到处活跃。所以奥本海默本也可以活到那时的，谁知道呢，他的职业生涯会把他带向何方。不管怎样，汤姆，你是克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影迷吗？我不觉得你是，还是说你是？不，我确实喜欢克里斯托弗·诺兰。
the paradox isn't it that he's a man so unsuited and that's what makes it so appealing so that's oppenheimer he died in 1967 from cancer he'd smoked and drank all his life it's the smoking I think that got him he was 62 years old and had had this life packed with drama but Teller his great foe he lived to about 100 and he was you know knocking around at the end of the 20th century so Oppenheimer could have been as well and who knows you know where his career would have taken him. Anyway, are you a Christopher Nolan film fan, Tom? I don't see you as a, or are you? No, I do like Christopher Nolan.
我在飞机上看过《盗梦空间》。看过《盗梦空间》的人都知道，你不会想在飞机上看这部电影。有点迷迷糊糊的。我睡了又醒，根本不知道发生了什么，但这确实是看克里斯托弗·诺兰电影时的那种感觉，但它是一部如此令人难忘的电影，他的所有作品都在某种程度上玩弄时间和空间，确实如此。所以你可以完全理解为什么它对有吸引力，我想，但我没看过这部电影，所以我不知道。你看过《记忆碎片》吗？
I watched Inception on a plane. And anyone who's watched Inception will know that you don't want to be watching it on a plane. Kind of slightly groggy. I slept and woke up and I had no idea what was going on but that's very much the feeling in a christopher nolan film is but it's so it's such a haunting film and all his work is kind of makes play with time and space and it does so you can absolutely see the appeal to him i guess but i haven't seen the film so i don't know have you seen memento
那是我的最爱，那是一部出色的电影。那真的是一部好电影。如果你从这个播客中什么也没学到……你知道我很喜欢《敦刻尔克》吗？很多人……有些人不喜欢它，因为他们不喜欢导演在时间上做文章。我太喜欢那些了。我喜欢在时间上搞点小把戏。
that's my favorite that's a brilliant. That really is a good film. If you've taken nothing else from this podcast... Do you know I did like Dunkirk? A lot of people... Some people don't like it because they don't like them messing around with time. I loved all that. I love a bit of messing around with time.
但一部以一个士兵朗读丘吉尔的话结尾的电影……哈里·斯泰尔斯。哈里·斯泰尔斯。一个朗读丘吉尔的人。还有一点埃尔加音乐。我想你无以复加了。每个人都能各取所需。所以非常期待《奥本海默》。好。奥本海默和汤姆就聊到这里，我们将会带着
But a film that ends with a soldier reading Churchill... Harry Styles. Harry Styles. A man reading Churchill. And a bit of Elgar. I think you can't beat it. Something for everybody. So looking forward to Oppenheimer. Right. That's enough of oppenheimer and tom we will be back with the
关于约柜和圣杯的巨大兴奋回归。所以约柜是另一件大规模杀伤性武器，是的，还有圣杯。如果你能从这两个标题中嗅出一个戴着软呢帽、挥舞着牛鞭、由汤姆·霍兰扮演的男人的身影，那么你绝对猜对了。嗯，希望大家喜欢这个关于奥本海默生平的两部分专题。这不是一个
tremendous excitement of the ark of the covenant and the holy grail so the ark of the covenant another weapon of mass destruction yeah and the holy grail and if you can sense in those two titles the shadow of a man in a fedora hat with a Bull Whip being played by Tom Holland, then you are absolutely right. Well, I hope you've enjoyed this two-part survey of Oppenheimer's life. It's not a subject
我真的很了解的主题，多米尼克。我不会称之为杰作，因为你只会笑话我，但它真的非常好。非常好。谢谢你，汤姆。它为去看电影做好了很好的铺垫。
I really knew very much about, Dominic. I'm not going to call it a tour de force because you'll just laugh at me, but it was very good. Very good. Thank you, Tom. And has nicely set up
太棒了。物理测试将随后进行。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
going to see the film. Excellent. The physics test will follow. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝演艺圈八卦的每周必备节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集和抢先购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、专属加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。